escaping the 9 to5 grind is actually
very difficult you just get sucked into
being busy the job kind of chews up all
of your time from 9:00 a.m. to 5:00 p.m.
you get home you're exhausted how are
you supposed to work on anything else so
I think the key there is trying to find
a career or a job where you will end up
in a business where the inputs and the
outputs are disconnected nowadays you
have knowledge worker jobs you have
intellectual jobs programming being my
favorite example where a good devel
veler can write a piece of code that can
literally make your business hundreds of
millions of dollars so if you can
navigate towards a career where you're
tracked on the output you're going to do
much better if you like animated videos
like this check out media plug using the
link in my bio